ADRIAN BASCHUK: First,
let me start off
by saying that I
freaking love Nepal.
I've been here three
times in the last 10 years
covering everything
from the Maoist rebels
to the country's
failing health system.
It is such a study in contrast.
I mean, it is the
Himalayan kingdom
replete with some of the
greatest natural beauty
unparalleled on Earth.
And yet, it's one of the
poorest countries in the world,
as well.
When I heard about
the earthquake,
I knew I had to get here.
There was some foundations that
were bring volunteers over.
So I hitched a ride, and here
I am on the ground to see it.
And right off the bat,
we're looking at a tent camp
here where people have been
sleeping out in the open.
And you can see this building
literally right here,
the entire outer wall is
just missing and collapsed.
And yet all around
on this block,
it's seemingly untouched.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
There's a big aftershock
show right here.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Whoa.
Everything's swinging.
The trees--
The ground just keeps swaying.
So you literally feel like
it's just still going on.
It's like both
sides of the street.
You've got that building
that's just leaning over.
And this rubble here.
Rubble here, crushed car there.
It's really, really
overwhelming.
So we just came across
this house here.
Looks like an
accordion, literally.
It's like some houses
were spared here.
And then you've got
a house like this.
Your house?
SPEAKER 1: Yes,
this is my house.
ADRIAN BASCHUK: I'm sorry.
What do you do now?
How do you rebuild?
SPEAKER 1: Nothing.
ADRIAN BASCHUK: Do you move?
Do you go somewhere else?
SPEAKER 1: Yeah, this ground.
ADRIAN BASCHUK: In a tent?
SPEAKER 1: Yes.
ADRIAN BASCHUK:
But your family OK?
SPEAKER 1: Yes,
all our family OK.
ADRIAN BASCHUK: Yeah?
So that's most important.
SPEAKER 1: Most
important, family OK.
ADRIAN BASCHUK: Walking
around here is no easy task.
I walked along this path here
and then came across this.
What the hell?
I mean, this is a whole
city block demolished.
Because you're the
commanding officer here,
what's going on
with this building?
It's literally like
a 60-degree angle.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
ADRIAN BASCHUK:
What's going on here?
How about you?
Where were you?
What happened?
Sankhu's a town northeast of
Kathmandu towards the epicenter
of the second earthquake.
It's 3,359 years old.
I filmed there after
the first quake,
just before the
second one, and can't
imagine what it looked like
after already being hit hard.
They were rebuilding in
Sankhu, in Kathmandu, and all
over Nepal, and this
second quake hit.
And now, there have been 24
aftershocks here since then.
But in a weird way,
they ground you.
They make you realize the
power of nature, sure.
But more than that,
the earth rumbles.
And despite tragedy, you
see people strive and go
on no matter how
shaky the ground.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER 2: On another
episode of "Seeker Stories"--
ADRIAN BASCHUK:
So we're basically
going undercover here.
Yeah, those were cage
of bears, I think.
Stop, stop, stop.
So there's one, two, three,
four, five right there.
SPEAKER 2: This episode is
a part of "Seeker Stories."
To see all the stories we post
here, be sure to subscribe.
Thanks for watching.
[MUSIC PLAYING]